[موسيقى]
كوميديون مراهق بدا رحلته بالادوار
الصغيره وغير الموفقه لكن الطياره اخذه
الى بر الامان عندما بدا في ظهور كبطل
خارق انه كابتن امريكا المنتقم الاول
ومحارب الشتاء فما قصه كريس ايفانز الذي
مجده الصغار قبل الكبار
1981 في بوسطن وعاش طفولته وهو شغوفا
بالرسم والتلوين لكنه تحول لحب المسرح بعد
ان راى صديقته تستمتع بالعاب الدمى
والمسرحيه كما استفاد من كون والدته مديره
فنيه في مسرح للشباب
فشارك بالمسرحيات المدرسيه قبل ان يلتحق
بمعهد لتمثيل في نيويورك
الفنيه عام
1999 كانموذج تايلر في لعبه ميستريديت
ولكن احلامه كانت اكبر بكثير فذهب
الاختبارات اداء الافلام والمسلسلات وكان
من اوائل مشاركته دور ثانوي
عام 2001 في الكوميديا التلفزيونيه
في دور نجم كره القدم الوسيم وهو العمل
الذي حصل على انتقادات سلبيه شارك كريس في
بعض الادوار الصغيره مع بدايه الالفيه حيث
شارك في مسلسلات الكوميديا تلفزيونيه مثل
استكواك وذا بيرفكت سكور قبل ان يجد مكانا
له على شاشه الكبيره عام 2005 في دوري
طوله البشري جوني ستورم في فيلم فانتاستك
4 لكن هذا الفيلم لم يلقى استحسان
المعجبين واجهت كريس خلال مسيرته المهنيه
الكثير من الاخفاقات فحاول الابتعاد في
مكان يمر بنوبات من الهلع والاكتئاب حتى
عرضت عليه شركه النشر العالميه مارفل
كوميكس عام 2010 دورا في فيلم فيرست
افينجر
رفض كرس العمل لظروفه النفسيه لكن مكالمه
من الممثل والمنتج الامريكي روبرت داوني
جونيور رفعت معنوياته عندما نقل له تجربته
الناجحه في التخلص من الادمان ودعاه للنور
فقبلت دور وظهر في سلسله افنجرز بشخصيتك
كابتن امريكا ليصبح احد ابطال مارفل
خارقين المحبوبين وممثلين هوليود الناجحين
كما حصد بسبب هذا عددا من الجوائز حيث فاز
بجائزه سكوين عن افضل بطل خارق عام 2011
وتم تكريمه بجائزه ام تي في موفي كافضل
ممثل مقاتل عن فيلم ذا افينجرز 2013 وحصل
ايفانزا على جائزه تين تشويز عن نسخه
الفيلم افنجرز ايج اوف الترانس عام 2015
وجائزه بيبوزيد شاي كافضل ممثل مقاطع تصعد
نجم ايفينز ونجح في الحصول على ادوار
المهمه فظهرك قائدا لثوره التصدي للاحتباس
الحراري
جائزه جوبيتر عام 2021
تبلغ ثروه كريس ايفانز 80 مليون دولار وفي
رصده نحو ثلاثه وخمسين عملا حصل خلالها
على عدد من الجوائز والتكريمات جعلته
مؤهلا لادوار بطوليه فيم ينتظر ان يظهر
لاول مره الى جانب نجم القتال دوين جونسون
بفيلم عيد الميلاد القادم
ريد 1 ليصل رحله من النجاح جاءت بعد الفشل
والاحباط
[موسيقى]